hello everyone we're here at cube con
Barcelona and with me is vinayaka's he
is one of the most humble engineers I
know he wants me to introduce himself as
a software engineer but he is co-founder
one of the original cofounders of
kubernetes as well as a co-founder of K
native so let's start with kubernetes
can you tell me about how its evolved
over time and this is probably one of
the biggest Cube cons we've been to this
is amazing it's amazing how it keeps
growing every year you come in and you
just see how much it's growing how many
new users are coming the solutions that
people are building on top of kubernetes
it just beyond wildest dreams of when we
started it yeah it is absolutely crazy
there are so many people now you've been
involved with a new project Kay native
which has turned into a hosted Google
solution called cloud run can you tell
us a little bit more about that sure
so Kay Native grew out of the fact that
we would like kubernetes is great but
it's really hard for the developers to
use there's a lot of pieces you need to
understand about it so I like to think
of it always as kubernetes we did the
cloud native assembly language and with
the Kay native we are building tooling
on top of it that allows people to then
build cool things on top of that so it
started out as an an open-source product
called Kay native it provides server
address' complete computing primitives
and building blocks that you can go
ahead and use to build your own software
much easier rather than having to deal
with the native primitive kubernetes
resources and it is also an API spec so
what you see is on the cloud run we were
able to go ahead and provide a hosted
product where you can use the API
without not even having a kubernetes
cluster to manage yourself but we
understand that there's a lot of
environments we're gonna provide these
computing capabilities so cloud run is
one where you don't even see any cluster
there is no cluster it's the cluster
let's compute and then all the way to
your own hosted if you have a bare-metal
kubernetes you can run it on there and
we are seeing more and more products
also being built on top of key natives
so cloud runners
them there's others pivotal read pad
I think franchise response something
yesterday or today so it's it's prone as
well nice so what is the current status
of K native end of cloud run sure so we
are in the K native side we are on a
six-week release schedule so every six
weeks we will cut ami release we have a
couple of different stacks there so we
want to make sure that you can come in
and either take all of them then I think
the term being described is Voltron
effect when you use all of them together
everything works much much much better
but you can also go ahead and come in
and host only the pieces that you care
about so some of those are serving and
inventing also has build so if you for
example have your own build system
you're happy with that
great we don't care you can just use
serving or eventing itself so what we
are working on the serving side is
really closely we have worked in very
hard to getting it to 1.0 release we
just dropped two weeks ago point six and
eventing is little bit behind so we are
gonna go and release serving first and
then event in but hopefully in the
sometime in the fall time period will be
in the 1.0 release so as a customer why
would i choose to run on cloud run ease
of management so you don't have the care
about you just give us the code and we
run it for you scale it down to zero so
you truly get the server less benefits
of scale to zero pay only for what you
use request based and so forth so on the
cloud run on the hosted you just give us
the code we run it for you and you don't
have to worry about managing anything
you can also do this on jke so we have
cloud run on gke where if you have a
cluster or you have other computing
needs that you want to go and do on GTA
ii then but then the great thing is that
you can just go and install the cloud
run gk add-on and then you can go ahead
and still use the same API so you can
pick and choose and then of course you
can install the open-source k native
yourself don't do any cluster any
kubernetes customer very cool so
basically you can use the the k native
API through cloud run but if you want to
drop down into a lower level you can
basically go in access that you
cluster directly that's correct very
cool so where are we going in the future
what are you excited about next I'm
excited about a couple of different
things one of them is getting getting
the GA on one point overlays but we feel
that it's it's it's ready to go the
second thing is seeing the community
girl so again kind of like what we see
with the kuru ladies in the early days
is like it's great to go and come up
with thoughts and ideas and share them
but what's really interesting is when
people start then building products on
top of that like we've seen as well as
the users so we are seeing a lot of
developers coming in and joining the
community and providing providing a lot
of great ideas great contributions it's
awesome that is great so last question
what are you looking forward to a to con
this year just seeing a lot of old
friends seeing all the cool things that
are being built and yeah just the
community it's just awesome all right
thank you so much for your time take
care
[Music]
you